Israel em Kirchner's professor emeritus
of economics at New York University he
earned his BA from Brooklyn College and
MBA and PhD from New York University
where he studied under Ludwig von Mises
an ordained rabbi and Talmudic scholar
dr. Kerzner joined the faculty at NYU
and 1950 1957 became a full professor in
1969 and taught until his retirement in
2001 he is written for several
publications including the journal of
political economy intercollegiate Review
the Hillsdale report economic affairs
the freeman and eastern economic journal
he's the author of numerous books
including the economics point of view
competition and entrepreneurship the
meaning of the market process essays in
the development of modern Austrian
economics a 10 volume series of dr.
Kurtz collected works is currently being
published by the Liberty fund dr.
cursors work is an important part of the
economics curriculum here at Hillsdale
and has contributed greatly to the
overall battle of economic ideas I must
admit it has also contributed to this
economic students sleepless nights in a
battle for better test scores it is
therefore my great pleasure and honor to
introduce dr. a0 Kerzner
thank you very much for that warm
introduction I have been asked to speak
about the importance of Ludwig Mises it
is for me
both the pleasure and a challenge to
tackle this formidable task and it is a
special pleasure to do so at Hillsdale
College an institution which has for
decades unfashionably but proudly
announced its deep respect and regard
for this great neglected thinker scholar
and economist I myself take pleasure in
this task because Ludwig Mises was my
revered teacher who shaped and formed my
entire career as an economist but
although Ludwig Mises was certainly
important very important for my own
career my talk will go far beyond my
personal story
Mises is important for the intellectual
history of the 20th century and beyond
he will I suspect an indeed expect be
treated as an important figure in the
long run development of economic theory
future historians of economic thought
will I believe in hope be unable to tell
the story of economics in the 21st
century without citing the part played
by Ludwig Mises in the twentieth
nonetheless I will with apologies begin
my discussion of the importance of
Ludwig Mises with a brief account of his
importance for me personally I began my
studies under Mises in September 54 I
completed my doctoral dissertation under
his guidance and supervision in June 57
virtually all my writings and
publications over the following six
decades merely Express what I learned
from Mises not only in the years 54 to
57 but in the many subsequent year
of my attendance at his seminars and in
the many years during which I studied
and that means I sucked myself in and
agonized over his books and papers
although not all of my interpretations
of Mises have been accepted by all other
of Misa students I did believe that I
have succeeded in correctly grasping
what is central in the misison system I
was privileged to serve as Mises
assistant for a number of years not only
did Mises supervise my doctoral
dissertation which eventually became my
first book on earth with a foreword by
mrs. himself
it was Mises who suggested my
dissertation topic in doing so Mises led
me to develop a theme in Miss essien
economics which has illuminated my
understanding of economics in general
and has throughout my career inspired my
published work but as promised this talk
is not focused on Mises importance for
me it will demonstrate I hope Mises
importance in much more important
respects who was Ludwig Mises Mises his
dates for 1881 to 1973 is known
primarily as a consistent dedicated
continued ATAR of the Austrian School of
Economics and a consistent defender of
free-market capitalism
although he was educated at the
University of Vienna he was not exposed
to the Austrian ideas of menga birimbau
work and visa until he was well advanced
in his own doctoral studies his teachers
had been adherents of the German
historical school which in the pre-world
War one years of the 20th century still
dominated many institutions indeed in
the years before his receiving his
doctorate in nineteen six Mises had
published papers in that same tradition
in the year 1903
Mises tells us in the memoir written in
his old age he tells us that he read
mangas granderson apparently this
reading opened Mises eyes to a whole new
world of ideas
it was that reading of mangas book Mises
declared that turned him into an
economist after receiving his doctorate
Mises attended the seminar led by Benoit
murk who after an illustrious experience
as Austria's Minister of Finance
returned to academia at the University
of Vienna in 1905 in 1908 Mises embarked
on his first book which was eventually
published in 1912 under a title which
translated into English is the theory of
money and credit by the start of World
War one Mises was well established as an
economist in the Austrian Chamber of
Commerce Commerce a quasi governmental
body directly concerned with national
commercial and industrial policy after
the war Mises came to be recognized as
that institutions leading figure and he
was thereafter deeply involved in all
the critical issues confronting Austria
in the 15 years following the war in
these issues
he was particularly involved in
attempting to resist the massive
inflation of currency which threatens to
ruin the country and he was also
particularly involved to resist the
influence of the followers of Marxist
ideas who were attempting to introduce
socialism into the Austrian scene
besides all this work on public policy
Mises was on the faculty of the
University of Vienna with a preface Orio
title but he never did Windley
profession the professorial chair very
importantly Mises conducted a private
seminar the private seminar that met
regularly not at the university but in
his office at the chamber of commerce
this private seminar included some of
the best young minds in the social
sciences not only in economics but in
history political theory and sociology a
number of these brilliant young
intellectuals such as Hayek were later
to become world famous scholars Mises
was one of the leading intellectuals of
the Vienna scene during the twenties
it was he who attracted and stimulated
these brilliant young minds the books
which Mises published during these
Vienna years established him as a
leading proponent of classical liberal
ideas and a trations critic of socialism
early in the 30s
Mises published a book in which he
expanded his methodological and
epistemological ideas these ideas were
sharply critical of some of the more
fashionable views on the methodology of
the social sciences that were gaining
currency on the continent and in the UK
at that time by the end of of the 30s
Mises found himself severely I would say
viciously attacks for his unpopular
methodological ideas in addition the
pendulum of ideological thought in the
social sciences was swinging sharply
during those years in the direction of
socialist and interventionist policy
against which Mises was emphatically
doing battle most importantly the
political unrest developing in Europe
during the 30s and Mises own potential
danger at the hands of Nazi officials
led Mises to leave Vienna first for
Geneva and then in 1944 the USA all this
meant the breakup of the group of
intellectuals who had been fascinated by
Mises in Vienna when Lisa's finally
arrived in the US with mrs. Mises whom
he had married in Geneva
in 1938 12 years after having first
proposed to her and after years of
hesitation when he arrived with mrs.
Mises he was no longer a leader of the
of an Austrian school in fact there
really was no Austrian school at that
time Mises was now an almost 60 year old
unaffiliated academic whose ideas were
entirely out of step with what was being
taught by the new leading figures of the
American economics profession Mises
never did gain an academic position in
the United States commensurate with his
stature as a leading economist
nonetheless he did not shrink into a
bitter isolated unproductive old age he
continued to produce books and papers
while continuing to teach with the
support of outside sponsors at New York
University he found intellectual
comradeship in Leonard Reeves foundation
for economic education under whose
auspices he was continuing to publish
although he never did succeed in
attracting young Americans scholars of
the caliber of those who attended his
Vienna seminars he was teaching and
attracting a number of bright young
minds such as Murray Rothbard and others
on the 50th anniversary of his receiving
his doctorate his admirers published a
fist shrift in his honor a second
publication a two-volume fester ifth in
honor of Mises 90th birthday appeared in
1971 although he was ignored and or
belittled in the poet in the broader
post-world War post-world War two
economics profession there were still
many scholars and lay persons who
recognized his true stature and who
admired his intellectual integrity in
remaining utterly consistent with what
he believed on scientific grounds to be
the truth his uncompromising advocacy
have completely safe air absolutely free
markets while it rendered him extremely
unfashionable did on the other hand mark
him as a fearless inductive defender of
undiluted capitalism and drew the
support of a significant number of lay
conservatives Mises could not be ignored
after Mises death in 1973 his wife
continued to publish his writings and
lectures
Betina being grieves one of Mises
motivated and enthusiastic American
admirers published a massive monumental
bibliography of all of Mises works over
his seven decade career and as we shall
see his work has ever since his death
continued to attract the interest of a
significant number of young and
intellectuals both in the US Europe and
around the globe
now our brief survey of Mises life in
Korea might tempt one to conclude that
although Mises may have been a prominent
Vienna intellectual during the interwar
decades but this court not to permit us
now in the 21st century to see him as an
important 20th century scholar after all
it may be objected despite his earlier
prominence he appears to have been a
marginalised figure during the
concluding decades of his life his
central ideas came to be thoroughly
discredited by the mainstream of his
profession he never did after 1940
exercised direct influence upon students
in any of the leading universities of
his time the final four decades of his
life were thus spent in relative
obscurity with his published writings
being read during these years by a
rather small number of zealous adherents
none of whom was prominent in the
academic world or for that matter
prominent in any sense perhaps it may
thus be objected
Mises may have had some importance for
his small group of dedicated followers
but surely in the broader framework of
20th century scientific and intellectual
achievement he must be seen as no more
than a marginal figure my talk today
will seek to address this kind of
objection as you seek to demonstrate
that despite the studied neglect with
which his more prominent contemporaries
treated his unfashionable ideas those
ideas do qualify as important in the
larger framework of intellectual history
future historians of twentieth-century
economic theory will I am confident be
compelled to recognize that importance
the failure of the leading economists of
his own time to recognize that
importance will itself become a puzzle
with which future historians of economic
thought will be forced to grapple what
I'd like to do is to discuss first Mises
importance as both a pioneer of and a
consistent part consistent participant
in the debates surrounding the
demonstration of the incoherence
in fact the impossibility of central
socialist planning this alone certainly
qualifies Mises as an important
twentieth century economist second I
will dwell on Mises role in advancing
the subjectivist ideas of the Austrian
School of Economics ought to an entirely
new level the circumstance that this
advance occurred precisely at the time
when it was generally believed that the
Austrian school was no longer a vital
component of twentieth-century economics
that circumstance makes the that role
played by Mises even more dramatic and
important third the impact which Mises
writings have had on a new younger
generation of economists which in out
is creating a new wave of interest and
academic exhibition acceptability for
the subjectivist ideas of the Austrian
school there is every reason to see this
impact as both remarkable and important
let me take up the first of these three
themes Mises and the economics of
socialism in 1920 Mises published a
German language article in the
professional social science journal
which stirred wide interest and set up a
vigorous heated debate that is still
going on in that article Mises was
addressing attempts in the immediate
post-war work world war one years to
replace the capitalist economic system
with genuine socialism both in Austria
itself and elsewhere Mises attacks such
proposals not on ideological grounds but
on the basis of their try economic
science an understanding of how the
market system works towards a
coordinated pattern of resource
allocation reveals how under central
planning any pattern of resource
allocation achieved must be seen to be
chaotic inevitably contributing
contributing to global inefficiency and
economic disaster
two years later 1922 Mises followed up
his journal article with a full-length
book treatment of socialism that book
included a chapter virtually repeating
the central challenge that had
constituted the core of his earlier
article socialists have always
criticized capitalism as constituting an
anarchy of production obviously they
said a central plan must be a rational
improvement Mises demonstrated exactly
the opposite not only with central
planning not
succeed it must inevitably be a disaster
Mises argument demonstrating the
impossibility the impossibility of
central planning depended on the
universal need for economic calculation
any attempt to achieve efficiency at any
level requires the rational calculation
of the benefits and costs associated
with any proposed course of action each
step taken whether by Robinson Crusoe
isolated on an island by a participant
in the market system or by a central
planning authorities seeking to improve
societal conditions any step taken must
be taken with awareness of what that
step can bring in terms say of
additional output or consumption
purchase and of what that step might
cost in terms of alternatives which are
being sacrificed in order to take this
step Crusoe may make that calculation in
physical terms if he spends the day
catching fish he can compare the value
to him of the prospective fish with a
value to him of the fruit which he might
have obtained say by climbing trees
instead of catching fish a consumer in
the supermarket can compare the value of
any given purchase with the value of
alternative purchases a manufacturer can
compare the output obtainable from a
marginal unit of labour with the price
you must pay to hire that unit of labour
and so on
economic calculation but a central
planning authority in any advanced
complex economy has no way of making
such an economic calculation by
definition the fully socialized economy
has no market prices for resource
services because no market is permitted
in this economy for the sale and
purchase of resource services the
central planning Authority cannot ever
know
whether a step it proposes to take in
the production process is or is not
costing the economy more than it is
worth even if the centrally promulgated
plan succeeds in fitting all available
units of resource service into what
seems a coherent jigsaw puzzle solution
so that all plans projects all planned
projects can be carried out as planned
this does not in the slightest imply
that this centrally promulgated plan is
from the societal perspective efficient
the planners have no way of knowing
whether some other central plan might
not have been a far superior plan from
the perspective of the planners
themselves what operates to ensure that
in the free market system resources do
tend to be used for purposes which
thought which consumers find most
desirable not a Nakia production is that
producers are constrained by resource
prices it is the resource price
reflecting the potential bits of
competing producers who might put that
unit of resource to work in some
alternative industry which the
successful bidder must pay ensuring that
in his best entrepreneurial judgment
consumers value its marginal products
more highly than they value is
corresponding marginal products in
alternative industries no one claims
these calculations made by
entrepreneurial producers are
necessarily accurate of course producers
are less than omniscient not only in
regard to the future but even in regard
to present market conditions but at
least the market system does ensure that
production activity is calculated all
production decisions are made in the
context of anticipated resource prices
and of anticipated consumer goods prices
a
central planning authority lacking any
framework of resource prices must be
seen as operating in the dark even if we
imagine the socialist authorities to
permit consumers to compete with each
other in consumer markets quote-unquote
and thus to generate quote unquote
market prices for consumer goods these
authorities cannot by the very
definition of socialism refer to any
market and array generated resource
prices economic calculation under
central planning is simply impossible
efficient central planning is a
contradiction in terms this explosive
demonstration by Mises was precisely
that explosive it stirred a vigorous
even ferocious interwar debate first in
the German language continental journals
and several years later in the British
in the British economic journals by the
outbreak of world war ii despite strong
support for this mr. sheean argument by
friedrich hayek the bulk of mainstream
professional opinion was running against
Mises argument separate articles by
Oscar Lang gay and by AB Appeal Lerner
in the mid 30s
these were defenders of socialism these
articles deploying the newly fashionable
versions of equilibrium micro economic
price theory seemed to many influential
economists to demonstrate the
possibility at least of a centrally
planned economy which could operate with
resource quote/unquote prices generated
without any free market for resources in
the textbooks immediately following the
end of World War two it became the new
orthodoxy to recognize the problems the
problem posed so starkly by misses but
to maintain that ingenious
planners could bypass that problem
simple the mises and mosul Hayek never
did accept these solutions they
dismissed the idea of non market
resource prices that his prices created
without the benefit of profit motivated
entrepreneurial judgment our point here
however is not to demonstrate the truth
of Mises reasoning that's my focus
tonight in the face of criticisms
originating in the 30s our point is to
emphasize that throughout the debate
both in the interwar years and in the
post-world War two years the issues
raised by Mises in 1920 continued to
command the attention of economists of
all schools even when the Missis Ian
argument was being dismissed his critics
were forced to recognize the importance
and validity of the concerns raised in
that argument in fact by the end of the
century
Mises argument was no longer being being
somewhere else summarily dismissed
significant work was being published
forcing economists to reconsider their
earlier rejection of this argument our
thesis and this part of our talk today
is thus to point out that in this still
ongoing debate concerning economic
calculation under socialism Mises
contribution was unquestionably an
important one and widely recognized as
an important one it was a contribution
that kept his name importantly at the
center of numerous twentieth-century
controversies in regard to the phased
feasibility of socialism we shall have
occasion later in this talk to return to
the substantive issue of whether mrs.
position in these controversies ought to
be accepted we turn now to discuss Mises
importance in the second theme that is
in the ongoing development of the
Austrian tradition in the modern history
of economic thought
I give this section the title Mises and
the survival of Austrian economics as we
noted earlier the reputation of the
Austrian school in the larger economics
profession had by about World War two
reached a low point both Mises and Hayek
were no longer in Vienna many of the
bright young economists of Vienna of the
twenties fritz machlup gottfried
haberler Oskar Morgenstern and others
were in the United States scattered
among different universities some of the
main positions associated with the
leading Austrians had it was widely
believed being refuted thus it was held
that Hayek had been bested in regard to
macroeconomic issues by Keynes
Austrian capital theoretic insights this
means better bumper Burkean capital
theoretic insights had it was it was
believed been successfully rejected by
Frank Knight Mises a prior ISM as a
methodological foundation had been
widely discredited even Mises thesis
with declaring the impossibility of
central planning had as we noticed was
widely believed been successfully
repelled perhaps more importantly a
number of the younger erstwhile
Austrians honestly believed that what
was both valid and distinctive in
Austrian economics such as attention to
subjectivist insights or the idea of
costs being seen merely as foregone
opportunities it was believed that by
the end of the 30s these these insights
had been thoroughly absorbed into being
part of the generally accepted
mainstream understanding so that
upcoming former Austrians such as fritz
machlup Oskar Morgenstern did not
believe it was necessary to insist on
retaining any defining description as
Austrian it was they apparently felt
more productive for scientific purposes
to pursue economic theorizing
within the broader mainstream shared by
the most prominent names in the
profession at any rate all this meant
that for mid century historians of
economic thought the Austrian School of
Economics was a term referring to a
group of Viennese scholars that was no
longer an active element in contemporary
economics that was the scene at the
close of World War two
I remember this personally very well
when I began studying and in in the very
early 50s in the Austrian school was
treated in the in the textbook the
history economic thought as bygone but
something had been important not longer
important this was the scene yet today
some sixty-five years later we again and
again encounter young economists who
identified themselves as followers of
the Austrian tradition such a resurgence
of interest in the tradition thought to
have petered out two generations ago is
something to be noticed it is an
important phenomenon in the history of
economic thought and it is a development
for which Mises and his work must be
accorded a major share of the credit if
for nothing else
Mises importance must be recognized for
his role in generating this revival to
put it somewhere differently the
circumstance that Mises works since the
40s
eventually contributed significantly to
such a revival of Austrian ideas makes
that work the work after the 1940s and
Mises himself important elements in the
history of twentieth-century
economics how did all this come about I
believe that the story is not a simple
one and I believe it should be told as
follows during the 1937 1948 decade both
Mises and Hayek separately clarified the
earlier teachings of the Austrian
tradition in new ways which taken
together constitute at least in
reference
they constitute an important advance in
economic understanding precisely during
the period in which with what in which
it was widely held that the Austrian
school was already or was about to be
different Mises and Hayek were
significantly deepening that schools
teachings clearly the Austrian tradition
was still very much alive but the story
is even more complicated we mentioned
earlier that contributing to the
widespread impression that the Austrian
tradition was no longer alive after the
30s contributing to this was a feeling
among a number of younger Austrians and
I mentioned McLoughlin Morgenstern that
that which had been distinctively
important in the Austrian tradition such
as subjectivism and demand theory or the
idea of opportunity cost had been
successfully implanted into mainstream
economic theory although in retrospect
it may seem surprising the truth is that
even Mises at least in the early 30s
shared in the opinion that there was not
much substantive difference between the
economic understanding of the Austrian
tradition and that of other
quote/unquote modern schools of economic
thought such as the anglo-american
school as he described it and the school
of love sons while raising in school a
passage in Mises 19:33 book approvingly
cites the view that these schools and
the Austrian school are all expressing
the same fundamental idea although they
are separated by only their terminology
and by the peculiarities of presentation
these differences Mises then maintained
did not affect the shared substance of
their teachings I can only point out the
amazing amazing aspect of this paragraph
in in Mises I studied on the Mises in
the early 50s just twenty years later 20
years is nothing
no 20 years later Mises would never have
written or agreed to a statement like
that that there's nothing separating the
Austrian school from the anglo-american
Lausanne schools he would never have
said that he was emphasizing the
difference and yet that's what he wrote
in 1933 my position is that it was only
their experience of the ferocious debate
concerning the possibility of economic
calculation under socialism that
revealed to me season 2 Hayek by the end
of the thirties that this agreement
between the schools on substance had
almost totally evaporated defenders of
the possibility of central planning
we're grounding their case in the
teachings of mainstream price theory
while for Mises and for Hayek it was
price theory that demonstrated the
absolute impossibility of central
planning clearly it was necessary to
restate the established teachings which
they had imbibed with the Austrian
tradition in a way which should sharply
dissociate those teachings from what was
apparently and to mrs. dismay becoming
the new neoclassical orthodoxy in Mises
writings and separately in those of
Hayek during this 1937 1948 decades we
find therefore in sites being
articulated which had hitherto even in
the Austrian tradition been accepted
only implicitly
it is plausible to suggest that both
Mises and Hayek did not at least
initially see themselves as contributing
new insights to the Austrian tradition
it is likely that they saw themselves as
simply pointing out rather obvious
aspects of the market economy which the
refinements of the new mathematize
versions of mainstream microeconomics
apparently obscured in retrospect
however
I think we have to maintain that we have
to recognize these separate
contributions of Mises and Hayek as
constituting a major advance in Austrian
teaching this advance alert was not
fully recognized as such at that time
even by mrs. himself that advance can be
seen as an important deepening and
strengthening of the Austrian
subjectivist understanding of how the
market works in retrospect we can also
recognize that as younger economists
during the later decades of the 20th
century came to appreciate these new
contributions of Mises they came to
appreciate his work more generally and
thus to bring about the remarkable
Austrian revival that we have witnessed
so that I would strongly maintain Mises
must be acknowledged as an important
figure in 20th century economic thought
for this his pivotal role in deepening
and thus perpetuating the foundations of
the Austrian school Mises in Anka is
unquestionably the most important figure
responsible for the survival of the
subjectivist teachings of the Austrian
school in the in in the next few minutes
I will brief I will try to show briefly
how this contribution to the advancement
of the Austrian tradition complements
and undergirds Mises critique of the
possibility of central economic planning
which with which we dealt with earlier
we have noticed that it was the
experience of the socialist economic
calculation debate that seemed to
brought home to me sis and also to Hayek
how far the new modern microeconomics of
the 30s had gone in abandoning the
earlier economic verities shared by
virtually all schools of economic
thought defenders of the possibility of
central planning believed that the
central planner
by deploying their understanding of
neoclassical price theory would be able
to generate non-market quote unquote
prices for research services which would
then make economic calculation possible
the planners would not be operating in
the dark these non market resource
prices would enable them to steer
resource use away from production
processes that are less valued by
consumers towards products and methods
of production in which these resource
services are fulfilling consumer needs
that are more urgently preferred
although this is not the place at the
time for a careful detailed dissection
of this mainstream counter-argument to
Mises is explosive demonstration of the
impossibility of economic calculation
under socialism nonetheless we should
take note of the following this
mainstream counter-argument is operating
with a price theory that is shaped
entirely by the theory of the perfectly
competitive while raisi in general
equilibrium state of affairs this
counter argument thus fails utterly to
recognize the entrepreneurial character
of free market processes which might
conceivably be held to confuse two
equilibrium states of affairs this
entrepreneurial character of the market
process entails our recognition of the
dynamic competitive process on the non
equilibrium conditions and requires also
our recognition that it is
entrepreneurial alertness to profit
possibly pure profit possibilities and
those possibilities are possible only
under non equilibrium conditions which
is the element that makes possible
expanding mutual awareness on the part
of market participants it is only the
entrepreneurial discoveries so made
which drive the market process through
which such expanding mutual awareness
might be achieved defenders of the
possibility of
economic calculation have not shown us
any substitute and the central planning
without the possibility of anticipatory
alertness the profitable market
opportunities that might correspond to
this entrepreneurial process under a
central planning regime so what we have
seen here is the linkage between Mises
importance as responsible for the
celebrated interwar debate on the
possibility of socialist central
planning and his importance in the
deepening of and enhancement of the
traditional core subjectivist insights
characteristic of the Austrian tradition
the third thing that I mentioned earlier
is the Austrian resurgence a number of
younger economists came during the past
half-century to recognize validity and
depth in the subjectivist teachings of
the Austrian tradition particularly as
expounded by Mises a good deal has
already been written about this
remarkable development in modern
economics it was not a development
drawing on any unanimous new perspective
among these younger economists one can
hardly imagine a greater contrast than
that separating the world view of Ludwig
Lachman from that of Murray Rothbard yet
each of these scholars along with many
others played important roles in
inspiring younger curious skeptic
dedicated graduate students to
appreciate the contributions of lithic
Mises Karen Vaughan over two decades ago
wrote an entire book describing the
disagreements mocking this Austrian
resurgence Peter bet key has in his own
prolific writings and in his remarkable
influence upon today's crop of graduate
students played a key role in
contributing to the continued resurgence
of interest in the Austrian tradition
during the two decades since the
appearance of Karen Vaughn's pioneering
work this resurgence has generated not
of course
anything like a revolution in mainstream
thinking we're not there yet but it has
generated an intellectual atmosphere
that has permitted significant numbers
of followers of the Austrian
subjectivist tradition in the United
States in Europe and around the world to
publish and teach something that a half
a century ago could hardly have been
imagined only time can tell whether this
resurgence now almost a half-century old
will continue and expand and perhaps
leave a more permanent imprint on the
wider world of economic thinking but as
we consider the life the work and the
long-run importance of Ludwig Mises
surely the Austrian resurgence demands
that we acknowledge Mises decisive role
in this intellectual development this is
part of why Mises is indeed important
but I want to conclude with in with a
new with a different theme thus far we
have spoken of lifting Mises as the
foremost scholar of the Austrian school
certainly it was in that role that Mises
the economic theorist is best known but
the importance of Mises is not confined
to the history of his contributions to
the Austrian tradition or to the impacts
which these contributions made in the
broader economics profession the
publishers blurbed
to my own 90 tomorrow in 2001 book
Ludwig von Mises the man on his
economics that publishes blurbed
includes the following words the
importance of Litvak for Mises is not
limited to the realm of economics Mises
exercised enormous influence of the
thoughts of libertarians anti-communist
liberals and even traditionalist
conservatives during the post-war years
for Mises the tenets of classical
liberal political theory corresponded
profoundly with the fundamental truths
of economics that's what the blurb
writer wrote was
in other words Mises The Economist was
at the same time the passionate
intellectual defender of the free
society as envisioned in classical
liberalism Mises surely claims our
recognition as being important also for
the broader area of political ideology
and its intellectual foundations Mises
is fierce advocacy free-market economics
was founded not merely on the profundity
of his exciting insights it was grounded
in addition on his in his passionate
concern for the future of mankind and
for the retention of what he saw as the
crucial importance of civil liberty in
fact it was this passion which on
occasion provided fodder for his
scientific critics Mises his critics
claimed was permitting his ideology to
steer his science thus jeopardizing the
disinterested objectivity which Mesa is
constantly claimed should and did govern
his scientific work but the truth is
that Mises was completely sincere in his
belief that quai scientists it is
necessary to adhere to an attitude of
vert freiheit
that means value freedom that is Mises
full heartedly subscribes to mucks
laborious doctrine that a scientist may
not in his capacity of scientists permit
his own personal preferences to affect
his scientific conclusions a scientists
who considers pipe-smoking
to be a disgusting practice may not
commit that personal value judgment to
play any role in his scientific
investigations into possible linkages
between pipe smoking and the incidence
of different types of cancer the latter
investigation must be conducted in a
manner that would convince the public of
the validity of his conclusions even
worth that public to thoroughly enjoy
pipe smoking Mises certainly believed
his free-market economic theories will
be exactly the same even if he as an
individual citizen were personally to
prefer massive government regulations of
prices incomes and methods of production
because Mises believed that once it has
been established scientifically as Mises
the scientists believed that it had been
established once it has been assigned
typically established that massive
governmental regulation of otherwise
free markets tends to severely harm the
well-being of a nation citizens and does
say by seriously diminishing their
liberties Mises the citizen could not
remain silent the concluding passages of
Mises scientific treatise on economics
that's his human action constitute a
passionate plea for the recognition of
Mises scientific conclusion a scientist
a scientist who has scientifically
established that a certain press
practice drastically shortens man's
lifespan is not violating his vet
freiheit
by passionately emotionally pleading for
the end of that practice so that while
Mises the Austrian economist is
primarily important for his scientific
role we should certainly take knows of
his important work as a citizen
supporting the political ideology of
classical liberalism the ascendancy of
this political ideology Mises makes
clear in many of his writings is a
crucially important objective an
objective consistent with the
perpetuation of a prosperous
civilization Mises the important
austrian economists was at the same time
and certainly not accidentally the
important exponent of the civil benefits
of the free market society this facet of
Mises importance deserves to be
underlined in regard to one additional
aspect of Mises life and career this
aspect is his intellectual integrity
Mises
sometimes described as having been
intransigent this is not the place to
analyze Mises personality in all its
aspects all the lorda Tory observations
in my talk today who have not been meant
to constitute an overall assessment of
Mises character and goodness mrs. Mises
who certainly understood the goodness
represented by her husband's life found
it necessary in her personal
reminiscences of her life with him to
mention that Mises was at one time prone
to sudden fits the fierce anger that
terrified her certainly any complete
discussion of Mises as a person would
have to take into account many aspects
but it's positive and negative that have
not been dealt with in this talk but
that's not our purpose today our talk on
the presence of Mises would surely be
serious incomplete
seriously incomplete were we to fail to
point out that what may have appeared to
some as Mises intransigence must more
accurately and truthfully be identified
as or at least linked to his personal
and intellectual integrity Mises
suffered as we noted earlier severe
neglect at the hands of the economic
profession once the foremost figure at
the international level of scholarly
repute his final decades saw him scorned
by the Prix by the post wars leading
economists Mises calmly accepted this
without bending he continued to write
what he believed to be the truth
regardless of the consequences to his
personal scholarly reputation or his
personal financial situation critics may
wish to see this as evidence of his
intransigence obstinacy or whatever I
firmly believe this to be an expression
of Mises is absolute incorruptible
intellectual and personal integrity this
scriptures of mrs. Vienna seminar of the
1920s and early 30s by some of the
brilliant young scholars drawn to his
discussions make it apparent that Mises
permitted all conflicting opinions to be
freely expressed and considered in the
discussions Mises listened to all these
conflicting opinions but in his own
writings he insisted on stating and
repeating the conclusions which he
believed had been scientifically
established he refused to bend he
insisted despite all personal costs on
what he saw to be the truth we must
surely recognize the intellectual
integrity which this represents and
understand that that intellectual
integrity were stiffened by the passion
with which Mises the citizen viewed the
dangerous consequences to mankind of
failing to see these truths no
assessment of the importance of Mises
can ignore this aspect of his life and
career and the lesson which it holds for
all of us thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
since I stay here
dr. kerzner you talked about how there
was not yet a time for a revolution when
talking about the Austrian or surgeon
see for mainstream theories when do you
feel as though we will have actually a
revolution on economic ideas in the
mainstream that is up to you
[Applause]
thank you dr. Persian for coming and
speaking with us in a paper by Ludwig of
Lachman when you were engaging in debate
with him I he claimed there was an
intellectual linkage between Mises and
shackles collide --ax do you believe
that Mises thought is consistent with
radical subjectivism that Lachman
suggested I'm sorry could you repeat the
question I'm sorry I do you think that
Mises thought is consistent with radical
subjectivism as Lachman discussed okay
look the Gluckman who was a dear
colleague of mine he saw Mises as a
stepping stone to something higher than
Mises I disagree sharply with that with
that conclusion
he saw Mises as a step towards
subjectivism but not come not completing
the for the full the full trip towards
the complete subjectivism he saw George
shackle the great British economist as
the exponent of real subjectivism that's
lachman's view I disagree with that
I disagree with that I'm not sure that
now is the time to expound the
differences between mr. sheean
subjectivism and shackle subjectivism
shackle subjectivism taken to the
extreme I'm not claiming that shackle
himself always took it to that extreme
sometimes he did but he taken to the
extreme would would maintain that what's
gonna happen five minutes from now is
unrelated to what's happening now
because human beings have free choice so
there's nothing to stop everybody here
jumping in in 300 different directions
okay I believe that most social
scientists would disagree with that they
would agree they would certainly agree
that although it's certainly true that
human beings have free will and they can
change they can free choices nonetheless
what they're going to choose can be a
large extent predicted on the basis of
what they did yesterday so there's some
very subtle issues as to how far
subjectivism could go and you're quite
right that Luckman took subjectivism
further than than Mises that's part of
what I was was I would mention when I
mentioned Blackmun's name in the in the
in the paper and I'm from the Chelsea
area of New York also as a young man I
didn't have any preparation or
background in in economics so that's
quite an advantage over others the the
in my early adulthood I was thrown into
fifteen years of what in your book I
think you said was Mises market process
but it was run at a very fast speed
maybe two or three times faster than
people are used to and after it was over
and winding down I went to an economist
and I asked him what the heck happened
you know I wanted to know something
about what I had just been involved in
and fortunately very coolly he referred
me to your book so on Mises so your book
was the first book that I ever read on
economics and what a beautiful
experience that was you mentioned and I
only say this because you earlier
mentioned the German historical school
and I had I was blank slate and when I
read this I couldn't imagine how bad how
a school of thought or a powerful school
could you know I I just I just wondered
if you couldn't talk about it for a
moment just as you did in the book
enough to give us a sense of because I
think it was a shock to me and knowing
the history of the 20th century how an
entire school like this could exist
okay this gets us to rather significant
extent away from our topic for this
afternoon but let me say this I'm using
Mises own interpretation of the German
historical school he saw the German
historical school as denying economic
causation what he felt was that they
were claiming that the that what happens
in an economy is whatever the government
wants to wants to happen you can do it
but the economy is putty you can shape
it whatever way you want that there are
no that this is why Mises believed the
german historical school was such a step
backward even from the Classical School
which certainly Mises did not endorse
because they were absolutely objective
it's not subjectivist
but they at least they understood the
notion of economic causation and the
german historical school were denying
that either explicitly or implicitly
when Misa when I mentioned earlier that
Mises in 1933 subscribed to the idea
that all the so-called modern schools
angular American School of lisanna
whatever how he described it we're
saying the same thing what he meant was
that finally economists of all different
schools were realizing the emptiness of
the German historical school that's what
he meant at that time that's what he
understood as modern economics meant
post German historical school economics
that's that's that's where he understood
it and it was only later had that he
realized that there were different
versions totally different versions of
what should replace the German
historical school and I think that's
responsible for this remarkable change
between 1933 when Mises wrote this this
passage and my experience of him in 1952
less than 20 years later okay
[Applause]